How quickly the misery and destruction of war
has spread across Ukraine as Russia seeks to
impose its brutal will on the country. But is
the conflict now entering its most critical
phase? The question to Lieutenant General
Ben Hodges, former commander, US Army
Europe and my guest this week from Frankfurt.
This is going to be — that's why I mean it's going
to be a decisive week. A decisive week ahead on
whether or not we can bring — force the Russians
to culminate so that they can no longer attack.
The targeting of civilians and residential areas
prompted General Hodges to call for NATO
to impose a no-fly zone across Ukraine
but the alliance said no. Is this weakness
or wise tactics? And what if Moscow is
continuing threats to use nuclear weapons.
So it's almost like we are talking ourselves out
of taking more forceful actions that we should.
All that and much more on Conflict Zone.
Lieutenant General Ben Hodges,
welcome to Conflict Zone.
Thank you.
Can we start with the
recent Russian attack on the Yavoriv military
base close to the Polish border with Ukraine?
35 people died. This came after Russia had
warned that NATO weapons shipments to Ukraine
would be seen as legitimate targets. We
don't, of course, know if some of those
shipments pass through that base. But looking at
the proximity of the attack to a NATO border, how
serious is that for the alliance, do you think?
Well, I'm more concerned about the impact on
the facility at Yavoriv. This is a training center
that from the Soviet times that we, the U.S. Army,
and Canada, invested a lot of money over the
last six or seven years to turn it into a
meaningful training area, training
center for Ukrainian forces.
And that's what it was for over the last
several years. I don't know that it has
become a logistics hub or anything. I think the
Pentagon has been pretty close-mouthed about this.
But I mean, going after, going after that base,
also is a demonstration that the Russians still
have the capability to reach that far. And I
imagine they also intended this as a warning.
And a warning or an actual attempt to pull
NATO directly into the war? Do you think that,
do you think that's what they want to do?
No ... I do not think that they want to get
NATO into the war. That's, in fact, that's the
last thing that they want, is a situation where
you've got all 30 nations-plus against Russia. I
think this is more about them trying to interdict
the logistical lines of communication.
Do you think NATO will continue to supply
military assistance to Ukraine and will it
defend those shipments if necessary, directly?
For sure we're going to continue and in fact,
we've got to accelerate. We need to be doing
something on the scale of the Berlin Airlift,
with a sense of urgency. The next ten days
are decisive, in my view. The next 10 days, if
we accelerate and expand the delivery of support,
I think the Russians actually are close to
culminating — to reaching the point where
they can no longer continue the attack, if we
keep the pressure on them for the next 10 days.
There's a lot of focus on China right now,
the US is claiming Russia has asked Beijing
for military help. Potentially a
huge development, that, isn't it.
Well, this is important.
The Chinese have to decide
what they want their role in the world to be. The
Russians obviously are in trouble. They know it.
Not only are they recruiting Syrians to
come join the fight because their own
manpower shortage is growing increasingly severe —
and they need financial help, which is why they're
turning to China, and I think they're looking for
some material support as well. So China really has
an opportunity and an important decision to make.
But the possibility of an open military alliance
between the world's largest country
geographically and the world's most
populous nation — do you think NATO's even
considered such an alarming development?
Oh, there's no doubt the alliance
has been thinking about this. This
featured prominently over the past year in a lot
of the strategic thinking and the conversations.
Does it scare you?
No, because I just don't
think it's — I don't think it's going to happen.
Actually, there's not much advantage for China in
being handcuffed to a Russia that is going to be
destitute and without a friend in the world. Other
than energy for its own economy and easier access
to the Arctic, I don't see too many advantages for
China here. This is bad for business for them.
General Hodges, on the ground in Ukraine, the
battle for Kyiv seems to be gathering momentum.
Is this going to decide the outcome of this war?
I think that the Russians are not going to be able
to encircle Kyiv, let alone capture it. I mean,
look, for almost 19 days now they've been
trying to capture Mariupol. That should've
been the easiest city for them to capture, given
the proximity of their navy and Sea of Azov
forces there in Crimea and in Donbass, and yet
they still have not been able to capture Mariupol.
I don't believe that they're going to that
they have the ability to actually encircle
Kyiv. I was there five weeks ago. I've
been there several times. This is a very,
very large city on the banks of one of the largest
rivers in Europe, very complex urban terrain.
They don't have the manpower to encircle it.
But the failure, if Russia failed to take Kyiv,
that would be a catastrophic blow to them,
wouldn't it? Won't they have orders, won't
they have orders to keep on regardless, flatten
the city if necessary? Take it at all costs?
There's no doubt that they will continue
to launch rockets and missiles into Kyiv
the way they've done other Ukrainian cities,
which is why it's so important that the aid
that we are providing to Ukraine
include the capability to destroy
the rocket launchers and missile launching
systems that Russians are using. But this is,
this is going to be — that's why I mean it's going
to be a decisive week. A decisive week ahead on
whether or not we can bring — force the Russians
to culminate so that they can no longer attack.
And then, Ukraine has a more advantageous position
for whatever sort of negotiations are happening.
You clearly want NATO to do more to help
Ukraine than it's been doing. Last week,
you co-signed an open letter calling for the
alliance to impose a no-fly zone over Ukraine
"to avert and deter Russian bombardment,"
you said, "more must be done to prevent
more wide-scale casualties and the potential
bloodbath." Do you feel NATO's been too soft?
I think that we are overreacting to Russian
threats about expansion of the war, about nuclear
weapons. I don't believe that the Kremlin will use
a nuclear weapon. I don't, you know, first of all,
Putin cannot do it by himself, and I don't believe
that the people around him are actually interested
in this becoming a nuclear threat. So it's almost
like we are talking ourselves out of taking more
forceful actions that we should. We are talking
too much about what we can't do and what we won't
do, and not enough about what we, what we can do.
Look Srebrenica, July 1995, European troops under
a United Nations mandate, stood outside
the city, while Republika Srpska forces
murdered 8,000 Bosnian men and boys. I do not
want us to be a part of something like that again.
Your letter said NATO leaders should make
clear that they won't countenance Russian
attacks on civilian areas, but they have
countenanced them, and they continue to do so.
And they turned down your proposal for the no-fly
zone. Does that concern you? That really they're
ceding the advantage to the Russians here.
You know, obviously, I'm not a very compelling
writer. Yeah, I do feel like that. We are we have
lost some momentum. The first two weeks of this,
I thought the White House was doing a terrific
job, the the allies sticking together and we're
still sticking together. But the last four days,
it feels like we began to become more risk averse,
more cautious, and the messaging was more about
no escalation and less about stopping the murder
of thousands of Ukrainian, innocent Ukrainians.
But there's an awkward dilemma here for NATO,
isn't there? NATO has to do what's right for
NATO. It can't necessarily do what's right for
Ukraine at the same time — the two
aren't necessarily the same are they?
I don't know that I accept the premise of the
question. You're right, Ukraine is not a NATO
member, and the alliance exists for the
collective defense of all of its members.
But if you accept the notion that what's happening
in Ukraine is not limited to Ukraine — and I don't
mean a stray missile going over the border,
I'm talking about what Putin is doing,
what is the impact on Europe, stability
and security in Europe, then I think
NATO has to take a broader view of this.
Joe Biden has repeatedly felt the need to state
publicly that the US won't directly intervene
against Russian forces in Ukraine. He did so
again last Friday. Is Biden pushing back against
domestic pressure for him to do more? And if so,
would you suspect that pressure is
coming partly from inside the Pentagon?
Actually, the Pentagon is usually the most
conservative institution in Washington,
so I don't think he's getting too much pressure
from the Pentagon to do more. Obviously,
the Joint [Chiefs of] Staff and the Department
of Defense are doing what they should do:
prudent planning, anticipation of requirements
and giving the president options. But I don't
think he's getting pressure from the Pentagon. The
Congress seems to be in a bipartisan way in favor
of doing a lot more. I think that the
president has overstated this business about
"No, we're not going to do this because it's
as if it's automatically going to be World War
Three." I don't know that I agree with that.
He — Biden — has delivered a strong warning
about chemical weapons, saying Russia would pay
a severe price if it used them. That's a that's
an easy threat to make. How seriously do you
take it coming from Biden? I mean, Biden was
vice president when Barack Obama gave a similar
red line warning to Syria, which did use chemical
weapons, but the warning never turned into
action. Could it be the same this time around?
I would think not. No. You're right that
President Biden was vice president during
the Obama administration when this famous
red line was given to the Assad regime.
The Assad regime jumped right over it
with Russian help and the U.S., U.K.,
France, Germany did nothing. And I think that
emboldened the Russians to go ahead and be even
more aggressive. So that's why President Biden
has not said this is a red line because that,
that figure of speech — you box yourself in. I
would anticipate, though, that there would be
consequences that would be even more severe for
the Kremlin, although we're running out of things,
other things to do to them short of kinetic force.
But chemical weapons is part of their
warfare doctrine, isn't it? I mean, they've used
it specifically against their opposition figures
like Alexei Navalny and some of those that
they've attacked on foreign streets in Europe.
A former U.S. official at the National
Security Council says Moscow accepts
the use of chemical agents in warfare. "The
stakes for Putin are existential," he said.
"If that's one more tool he can throw this
thing, he will." Do you think that's possible?
Yeah. I agree with Fiona Hill's comments
a few weeks ago when she was asked about
this and she said, oh, yes, he would. That
doesn't mean he will, but certainly I think
he would countenance countless myths, even
if it was not for state survival. But if it
was necessary to accelerate the extermination of
Ukrainians or to depopulate the area by getting
Ukrainians on the road. The most likely scenario
with chemical weapons is probably something like
Syria — chlorine, not the more... not something
like a nerve agent. Chlorine still kills people,
but the casualty rate probably is somewhere
similar to rockets artillery, but it puts
things in a different category. And certainly,
you know, the idea of seeing kids and old people
murdered by any kind of chemical weapon, any
kind of gas is going to put immense pressure
on the administration and other heads of state
and government to take action. And it should.
And those who will be most worried about the
threat of chemical weapons would be Eastern
Europe, Baltic states. They've been warning
about Russian aggression in the region for
some time, the question is why nobody's been
listening to their voices over the years.
Well, I think that there is a large part of
Western Europe that is further away from Russia,
but also inside the United States and inside
the UK, where you've got huge Russian money,
business, energy dependencies. So there's been a
reluctance to confront this for a variety of bad
reasons, and I would say shame on everybody that
said, "come on, Russia is not going to do this."
I live in Frankfurt. I hear it from friends all
the time before this happened: "Come on, what are
you worried about? It makes no sense. Putin would
never attack." And here we are. And unfortunately,
in the real world, you can't make your
threats go away by looking the other way
or wishing that they didn't exist. And
so we're paying the price for that now.
To date, NATO's reinforcements in those countries
don't have too much deterrent value, do they?
A few thousand extra troops, a few more
fighter aircraft. Not nearly enough, is it?
No, first of all, I would
completely disagree with you,
Tim, that they don't have much deterrent
effect. It's been pretty effective so far.
But I do agree with you that we don't have enough.
We don't have enough air and missile defense. We
don't have enough logistics. The ability to move
quickly across Europe is not what it needs to be
to really be a strong deterrent should Russian
forces move into Belarus in stronger numbers,
which I expect is going to happen thanks to this
bogus constitutional referendum in Belarus a few
weeks ago. Then this raises the risk for our
allies in Estonia, Latvia and Lithuania. So we
do need to improve air and missile defense. We
do need to improve the logistical preparations.
But I would also say, I think that the alliance
is now going to consider more favorably permanent
basing in Romania and Poland and Baltic countries,
not just rotational forces. I would support that.
And what do you think the
reaction from Russia would be?
Of course they will, they will complain about
it, but in my view, they're in no position to
complain. They've... we did not have permanent
basing in there since the NATO Russia Founding Act
because one of the provisions said no permanent
basing. And so we adhered to that. But when the
Russians abrogated the NATO Russia Founding Act,
with their attack in Georgia and then in Ukraine,
the alliance continued to live by that.
It's obvious that our good faith effort
has not been rewarded by good behavior by the
Russians. And so we need to replace that naiveté
with some serious deterrence measures.
You talked earlier about wanting to
stop Russia calling the shots, and
it's about time that the NATO alliance
called the shots. How should the West be setting
the agenda instead of responding to Moscow's?
Well, first of all, they need to be feeling pain
immediately and in a lot of different places.
The sanctions are important, the effects
are going to be felt for years to come.
But as you know, sanctions take a while to really
start delivering effect. Some inconveniences for
Russians now. But the real pain is going to be
felt in the coming months, to include, Russia
probably will default on 150-billion dollar debt
on loans because their economy is in tatters and
Aeroflot will not be able to fly anymore because
they don't have repair parts. And so there's going
to be serious impact in the coming months. But
more immediately, we need to be doing two things,
in addition, obviously, to providing
aid to the Ukrainians that they need.
Number one, we should be trying to reach every
Russian family and tell them what's going on.
There's a reason that the Kremlin has put a
media blackout all over Russia that social
media does not allow people to understand what's
happening. The older demographic in Russia,
of course, has completely bought into state-run
TV, but there is another part of the population.
I don't think so. There are still thousands of
Russians that have the courage to go out and
protest, the woman that we all saw on Russian TV
last night that jumped in behind the commentator,
with the sign saying "Stop the war". This
is there. On 1 April, on the 1st of April,
130,000 Russian families are required
to send their son to be conscripts
for the Russian army. If we could reach just
10 or 20 percent of that 130,000 and tell them
to resist and not send their son, I think that
would send a shockwave across Russia, and it
could really generate more domestic pressure.
That's hard to do, but I think this is doable.
General Hodges, you've been pretty scathing about
Europe's defense posture in the past. In your book
"Future War" you say that "Europe is finally
waking up from a 30-year strategic slumber,
but there's little unity of effort or purpose and
even less strategic direction." Any sign that's
changing in the last few days? The
idea that the EU would actually
ship weapons to Ukraine or anywhere else certainly
speaks to a sudden awakening, doesn't it?
Yeah. I would say it's been quite an awakening
and Germany has been the key here. When Chancellor
Scholz made his speech about three weeks ago there
in front of the Bundestag, where he talked about
2%, he talked about a hundred billion euros
and allowing weapons to move through Germany
or weapons over which Germany had some control,
this was critical. That, to me, was the door
slamming shut on any hope that Putin might have
had to separate the alliance or to divide the US
from Europe. German leadership here is essential.
Now German....it's not just the economy,
it's sort of the moral authority that Germany
has accrued over the last seven or eight
decades. And I think that German political
leadership, the so-called elites, realized that
they were in danger of seeing that credibility
erode right underneath their feet. They could
not claim to be the champion of European values
and of the "gesamte europäische Friedensordnung."
The peace and stability culture of Europe,
if they still abide while Russia smashed it.
What's what's alarming in your judgment is
the fact that while Russia is exploiting the
evolution in military technology, hypersonic
weapons, laser particle beam systems,
Europe, you say, has chosen not to. How
serious is it that Europe should actually try
to catch up with these advanced technologies?
Well, of course, if you want to defeat those
technologies or deter their use against you, you
have to demonstrate that you have the ability
to do that. Now, stand fast the fact that the
Russians have not been able to actually employ
very effectively much of these technologies. I
have been a little bit surprised that I have not
seen more cyber use. That I have not seen more
effective integration of their modern systems.
Did you overestimate their capabilities?
I did. I absolutely did. And I think as
I look back now, the missing ingredient, it's
not, it's not the device, it's not the platform,
it's the training and the culture of readiness.
And I think what we're seeing is the result
of decades of corruption and false reporting
inside the Russian defense industry and inside
the Ministry of Defense. A lot of money was
spent, but they didn't get what they paid for.
You said recently the Kremlin is
always in a war state of mind. But
NATO isn't, is it? And it hasn't been. Can you now
foresee NATO moving, excuse me, to the same kind
of war footing as Russia? Does it need to?
I think we're going to see more people
being more clear-eyed about the threat. I mean,
you know, we probably, first of all, couldn't
believe that there would be a big war in Europe.
Secondly, we were accustomed to what war
looked like in Afghanistan and Iraq, not
with missiles flying into buildings and thousands
of people being killed and displaced like we're
seeing right now. So we have forgotten about the
lethality of high end of war. So I think there's a
grim realization that if we want to prevent it,
that you have to be, you have to be ready for it.
What comes next, in your view, as far as the
battles are concerned in Ukraine? If Putin
won't accept to lose, and can't be seen to lose
in the international arena, what do you think
he would do? Is the West on a knife edge here?
And I don't think so. I think we've we have taken
too much counsel of our own fears about a nuclear
conflict and allowed him to use threats to keep us
from doing what needs to be done. I'm not saying
that there's no risk and obviously nobody I know
wants it to go that way. But I think we have
given him too much credit for the ability to
do those things, and we've deterred ourself. What
comes next? If I'm right that within the next 10,
10 to 12 days, Russian forces culminate,
they can no longer continue the attack.
They will obviously want to hang on
to what they've got. This is when we
should be pouring it on. We'll have a better
negotiating position and we should demand that
they go back to not just pre-February 24, but
what President Biden that Ukrainian sovereignty
is a priority for the United States, that they
should leave Crimea, they should leave the Donbass
and then we get on with recovery. I mean, there's
going to be more than three million refugees
that want to come home. This is going be a massive
problem to rebuild and help repatriate people. But
also, as you and your viewers know, there are
millions of people across Europe and the Middle
East that depend on grain from Ukraine for food.
We're going to have a serious food problem here
over the next year until Ukraine is able
to start exporting agriculture again.
And the humanitarian emergency that's now a
very real, a very all-present reality for people
in the major cities. People are living in what
one aid agency called apocalyptic conditions. We
just stand by and watch that for the time being?
Oh, of course not. There are dozens and dozens
of agencies that are out already trying to
help, particularly in Poland, where agencies
have moved there to help deal with refugees, and
some are working inside Ukraine. I know several
people who are personally involved in this, but
there's also going to be a part of the cleanup,
as you know, from all your years as a journalist
in a conflict like this. There is so much what we
call UXO — unexploded ordnance — everywhere. The
cluster munitions that the Russians have used,
rounds that did not detonate. This stuff is
lying all over the battlefield everywhere.
And so as people go back in and try to clean up
these cities, this is going to be a real problem
for quite some time. These nuclear plants, I
mean, we've got some cleanup to do there as well.
All right, General Hodges, it's been
good to have you on Conflict Zone.
Thanks very much indeed for your time.
Thank you. Thanks for the privilege, Tim.